hey guys what's going on so welcome to
our bathroom today we're gonna do a
little video that was suggested by you
guys and I've seen some other people do
this and it's pretty cool it is the
blind makeup challenge
now I've already blocked off old the
mirrors there's a mirror back here but
I'm not gonna cheat so don't worry and
if I look over to here no mirror if I
look up here no mirror I'm going to do a
really nice look that I would like to
wear out to the club to go dancing
I do neither one of those things I do
dance but not really in club settings so
first things first let's pull the hair
back okay make sure I flip this this is
what you look like it's you let's start
this Massacre off with some foundation
we're going to the club so weird cuz I
usually look right up and I see my
mirror is there I think I'm gonna do a
little Kim Kardashian contouring you
guys think I'd like to have some nice
high cheekbones for today for the club
see cheekbones a nice little Kim contour
feeling feeling good so Kim likes to do
a lot of like this is my nose that's
impossible I guess I watched some little
like makeup tutorial contouring thing
that she did before you want to look
real pretty especially for the club cuz
you want to be dancing and you want to
be dance I don't know something dude
comes up do you and us all like you know
you want to be ready you want to look
your best so I'm gonna set this with a
little bit of powder because you don't
want to make it look like you're wearing
makeup you know that's the trick you
want to make it look like you're not
trying too hard so when that dude was
grinding up on you at the club he's not
going to be like wow you spent three
hours on your makeup I didn't I'm
naturally that's beautiful we're gonna
use the Naked 2 palette hmm
oh no there's a mirror I'm gonna use
this dark color cuz I want to do a
smokey eye but I don't want it to be too
smoky you through my eyes first I've
never really done the smokey eye on
myself to begin with so I don't really
know
they look good god I'm gonna be so sexy
at the club girls and guys are gonna be
up on it you really hi what's your name
and I'm gonna be like Holly on Twitter I
don't know if this is a little heavy so
I'm gonna add a little bit of
highlighter because I don't want it to
be too dark especially in these club
lights I'm gonna want a little bit of
reflector that says hi I'm a dancer now
the reason that I'm thinking I'm gonna
do fake lashes is because I don't trust
myself with a mascara wand become happy
with this oh look what I found
glitter liner it's definitely a
statement the statement that I'm trying
to make it is I'm sexy yeah I know it
and if you stand to get dirt under there
another important part is eyebrows so
like you guys don't understand how
important eyebrows are and I never
really understood how important they
were because I used to have as you guys
told me I had sperm eyebrows a couple of
years ago so if you look at some of my
older videos you will notice that there
there's that so now I've let them grow
out a little bit but now you know
sometimes there's some sparse little
cysts faces so you gotta fill em in now
when I'm at the club there's gonna be
disco lighting there's gonna be flashing
lights and I want there to be no spaces
and my
I think this is where your Braille is
supposed to be and sometimes I like to
brush the brows to give them a little
more shape and definition which is
really important especially my color to
the club we put a little on here because
Kim Kardashian would probably do this
but that ended up I don't usually use
this but since we're going to the club
it's an exception I like to smile and
just you know apply it right on the
apples of my cheeks oh yeah you are so
beautiful I would like to put on I think
eyelashes now hi I don't have any glue
how am I supposed to put these on you
just you really want to get it as close
to your actual lashes as possible I
think that's good
the bad part is I can't see I can't see
what I'm doing it is some enrollment I
don't have any glue so I'm scared
because I can't see I feel really good
I've only worn it once and then when I
put it on I was like this is too
freaking bright and doesn't matter
though because I'm gonna go home to the
club I'm going to the club I think I'm
done I think I'm really done feels a
little off something doesn't feel right
yeah that's good gonna flip you guys
around one board down second board ahead
and look at oh my sweet sweet baby Jesus
oh my god it's not good at all it's
totally a sad sad clown
hey maybe I put my hair down to look
better whose eyelashes hey can you come
down here let me know honestly what you
think I make up 30 seconds okay you're
playing a game all right right you see
my makeup are you ready no what do you
think of it please tell me yeah your
eyes are real bad if I had to say your
best area was this stuff the bus yeah
your lips I guess is I guess fine
look at those big old eyebrows ha ha you
like oh there's nothing I can say that's
a good answer so I'm just gonna say that
you know for your eyes being shot you
did all right but this was my I'm going
to the club look so you're writing at a
club I would never go to the club anyway
so yeah but my lips this lipstick
actually looks really good though well
thank you guys for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this video and thank you to
everyone who suggested to do a no
mirrored application makeup video if you
have any suggestions for a future video
be sure to leave in the comments below
don't forget to subscribe and I will see
you guys in that next said video oh my
god now it's time for me to go to the
club